comment ça va
allô aujourd'hui on est le 21 juin c'est
la Journée nationale des peuplecteurs et
le mois de juin c'est aussi le Mois
national de l'histoire autochtone
dans cette vidéo ici en ce moment j'ai
goût de vous partager des petits trucs
que vous pouvez faire parce que c'est
quelque chose comme un monde souvent
je pense qu'il serait vraiment
intéressant de savoir sur quel
territoire autochtone tu vis en ce
moment ou quelle communauté autochtone
vit proche de chez toi je pense que
c'est une bonne première étape donc tu
peux commencer à prendre des petits mots
des petites termes que tu vas pouvoir
peut-être même utiliser au quotidien
puis aussi d'apprendre les noms des
communautés autochtones qu'on a ici au
Québec
je pense qu'on peut toujours aussi
s'informer en ligne il y a tellement de
ressources maintenant en ce moment donc
moi comment je fais c'est que je regarde
j'utilise beaucoup la plateforme
Facebook pour des événements il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'événements qui sont
écrits sur facebook après sur Instagram
sur Tik Tok j'utilise personnellement
les hashtags donc tu peux écrire comme
par exemple moi je suis abonné au
hashtag inweet donc mon compte
mes transfert des informations ou me
suggère je veux dire des informations
sur les autochtones et plus précisément
les Inuits ce qui est vraiment est
toujours important c'est de continuer de
supporter les artistes les personnes
autochtones avec leurs entreprises aussi
ou en étant artiste donc de supporter en
achetant en assemblée en écoutant des
documentaires des films
c'est vraiment important de supporter
aussi les Inuits des fois on oublie un
peu les communautés du Nord on va parler
des Premières nations mais on va oublier
les Inuits donc je vous fais un petit
rappel de aussi supporter les Inuits
merci beaucoup puis passez une belle
journée à plus bye